bonjour et bienvenue dans europe hebdo
comme chaque semaine nous sommes au
parlement européen à bruxelles et dans
cette émission nous nous demandons si
l'europe n'est pas en train de se
désagréger les italiens ont envoyé un
message anti système et anti austérité à
bruxelles et nous partirons également en
reportage à londres où 60 % des
britanniques veulent quitter l'europe
mais l'actualité c'est aussi la
commission européenne qui baisse ses
prévisions de croissance pour la france
et les chiffres ne sont pas bons pour le
reste de l'europe alors cette question
le vieux continent se dirige-t-il vers
le déclin on les attendait ces chiffres
la commission européenne a publié ses
prévisions de croissance pour les 27 de
l'union européenne c'est à dire c'est
même catastrophique pour certains pays
de la zone euro c'est finalement une
croissance de 0,1 pour cent pas plus ce
qui est prévu pour la france en 2013 il
y a ceux qui sont pessimistes avec cette
croissance quasi nulle
l'objectif du déficit public à 3 % c'est
impossible à atteindre
il y a ceux qui sont optimistes aussi je
suis conscient qu'en matière de
croissance
ce sont les chiffres de la commission
pour 2013 notre vision immédiat reste
difficile mais je veux le dire aussi aux
français l'espoir de la reprise se lève
l'espoir se lève mais la panne de
croissance concerne toute l'europe pour
le moment avec des pays plus durement
touchés que les autres par la crise la
grèce et l'espagne et leur taux de
chômage de 27%
l'hebdomadaire libéral les économistes
est catégorique l'europe décline
l'europe est en train de perdre son
leadership économique et le journal de
prédire le classement pour 2022 des
puissances économiques dans le monde au
top les états unis devant la chine le
japon et l'inde le brésil à la sixième
place le premier pays européens
l'allemagne la france n'occupait plus
que la neuvième position de ce
classement contre la cinquième
actuellement bon l'hebdomadaire est
anglais donc pas forcément objectif en
ce qui concerne la france
mais quand même l'europe a désormais la
réputation d'être l'enfant à problèmes
de l'économie mondiale et se fait donner
la leçon par les capitalistes chinois ou
les économistes indien de là à parler de
déclin
il y à un pas que les plus optimistes ne
veulent pas franchir
alors l'ordre va vers le deck la vaste
question dominique riquet bonjour vous
êtes député européen membre du ppe parti
populaire européen vous est aussi vice
président de la commission des
transports et du tourisme alors est ce
que vous êtes optimiste ou pessimiste
sur l'europe
est ce que l'europe lors va-t-elle vers
le déclin alors optimiste parce que on
s'engage pas dans politique la politique
européenne sur des populistes europe
connaît une grille c'est clair ne va pas
vers le déclin je pense que ce
elle est en train de se relever elle
prend les mesures possibles on l'avait
dans le sujet 0,1 pour cent de prévision
de croissance pour la france à tout
chômage de 27% pour la grèce et
l'espagne est ce que la politique de
rigueur l'austérité c'est la bonne
solution
alors je pense que la difficulté tient
dans le fait qu'on doit arriver à un
équilibre entre le redressement des
comptes publics est nécessaire parce
qu'à un moment donné sinon si la dette
nous étouffe
on peut pas continuer à fonctionner mais
il faut également et en même temps
préserver des marges de relance et la
capacité d'encourager la croissance soit
que celle équilibre entre les deux pieds
d'être difficile mais nous devons tenir
d'accord on l'a dit vous faites partie
de la commission des budgets les 27 pays
de l'union européenne se sont accordés
sur un nouveau budget pour la période
2014-2020 jeu budget pour la première
fois il est en baisse 1 c'est la
première fois de son histoire le
l'europe veut l'europe au pain sec et à
l'eau
qu'est-ce que quel impact cette
politique d'austérité aura pour les pays
de l'union européenne
je pense c'est un très mauvais budget
pour beaucoup de raisons parce que on ne
peut pas considérer le budget européen
comme le budget des états membres
parce que c'est un budget qui repart
d'ailleurs aux états membres qui est
essentiellement destinée à soutenir la
croissance donc c'est à la fois un
mauvais signal pour la croissance c'est
un mauvais signal pour l'europe parce
que le rap a besoin d'avancer dans pas
de reculer et enfin je n'ai pas observé
d'ailleurs que les états manquent
diminuer leur budget leur propre budget
bien au contraire puisqu'il 24 états
membres sur 27 encore significativement
augmenté leur budget comme la france de
0.46 mes enseignements sur bordeaux
c'est pas un bon budget c'est pas un
budget pour la croissance je pense qu'il
faudra discuter de ça d'accord vous
faites partie de la commission des
transports le budget pour les
infrastructures a été taillée ce que
vous allez le voter ce budget ou s'est
levé tôt
le budget pour les infrastructures est
catastrophique puisqu'il a été
dilué de 40 % par rapport à la
production à la proposition de la
commission
or c'est un budget trois sens par
définition parce que faire des
infrastructures de transport de
télécommunication ou pour l'énergie
c'est préparer l'avenir préparez-le
défis environnementaux et puis générer
de la croissance immédiatement et la
compétitivité après c'était vraiment le
budget est 40%
donc franchement là les députés
européens ont le pouvoir le parlement
européen a le pouvoir de d'accepter ou
de rejeter en bloc de ce budget ça va se
passer en juillet vous allez voter ou
pas à moi personnellement dans les
textes des changes ne voterait pas ce
budget comme d'ailleurs bon nombre de
mes collègues j'ai été quatre principaux
partis --quatre président fait une
déclaration pour dire qu'en l'état il
n'était pas recevable c'est pas avec un
budget de cette nature qu'on va faire
avancer ni l'europe ni la faire sortir
de son problème de la raison principale
c'est là qu'elle voit la raison
principale c'est que est ce que vous
pouvez donner à l'europe pour 2020 et à
budget qui est inférieur à celui de 2006
alors que nous avons des défis à relever
à d'élargissement des problèmes de
croissance a relancé
ça me paraît impossible l'on parle d'une
d'une clause de révision en 2016 en cas
de retour à la croissance
est-ce que cela je grand mère elle
disait cd prometteuse bonjour c'est à
dire sur on verra plus tard
moi je pense que un budget acceptable il
dédia c'est mieux qu'un promesse d'un
budget qui sera peut-être acceptable
ultérieurement
je crois que c'est maintenant que les
gens 23/100 je pense que le message des
peuples européens il a été clair les
gens disent à message contre l'europe
moi je pense que c'est surtout un
message pour des politiques qui sont pas
obligatoirement équilibrer la chance de
faire de croissance à travers le budget
européen il faut la prendre
l'actualité c'est aussi les élections
législatives en italique sais pas c'est
une gifle à l'europe
ce résultat c'est surtout une gifle
système politique italien au premier
chef au deuxième check ya aussi un vote
de défiance je crois en vers l'europe ou
plus exactement vers l'europe telle
qu'elle est perçue par les italiens
à travers leur propre classe politique
est là il ya un problème
moi je reviendrai pas sur le fait que
beppe grillo apparemment il avait un
métier de comics il fait 25% d'ivoire
d'italie ça se passe de commentaire
dominique riquet merci d'avoir accepté
cette invitation donc l'autre sujet
d'actualité c'est bien évidemment les
élections législatives en italie est un
pays ingouvernable les télévisions
européennes en ont parlé
c'est le zapping les résultats des
élections italienne devrait avoir des
conséquences sur les pays de la zone
euro à bruxelles
on craint que se voir très serré
novembre de la télé gouvernable si la
grande préoccupation au sein de l'union
européenne les résultats sortis des
urnes en italie rendent le pays
difficile à gouverner
surtout à un moment où on a besoin de
stabilité pour affronter les défis
économiques
ce mot est compréhensible par tout le
monde a la une du journal
un bout vers nabeul l'italie en l'état
actuel des choses tout simplement parce
que les deux chambres sénat comme
chambre des députés ont strictement les
mêmes pouvoirs et que si le centre
gauche a une majorité absolue à la
chambre des députés
elle n'est que toute relative au sénat
et que beaucoup de ces projets de loi
bien nous ne passerons pas pour être
bloquée à tout moment situation délicate
en italie après les législatives les
résultats définitifs tarder à tomber
la gauche devrait s'imposer à la chambre
mais elle pourrait bien ne pas avoir la
majorité au sénat
un scénario redouté par l'europe et par
les bourses qui sont passés dans le
rouge un moment selon la règle il est ce
que tu es grillo est un comédien qui
s'est insurgé contre la classe politique
italienne mais contre l'austérité et
veut faire un référendum sur l'euro un
italien sur quatre a voté pour son
mouvement de protestation alors nous
sommes avec josé pays n'a pas terni si
vous êtes la correspondante de la
télévision italienne rai ici à bruxelles
alors on l'a vu sur les images beppe
grillo c'est l'amuseur qui ne fait plus
rire personne
il est en position d'arbitré que fat il
faire de ces élus donc il a dit qu'il va
changer la conception des années
en serre comme on l'a bien jusqu'ici et
probablement ils cherchent de faire des
alliances mais réforme sur réforme donc
pas le lien ce stade stable pour un
gouvernement mais quelque chose pour
changer le système avec des lois qui
sont les lois qu'il a présentée dans son
programme il n'est pas très connu
c'est qu'il est aigri c'est l'extrême
gauche et l'extrême droite
donc c'est un mouvement qui s'est très
mélangées mais il faut comprendre que le
mouvement est né dans l'est dans les
ruelles et avec les institutions d'aidé
d'intégrer aussi et sur la web donc
c'est à dire sur twitter c'est à dire
sur le blog etc
mais on a surtout je pense dans ce
groupe on a quelque chose de très fort
que les italiens veut dire à la
politique
est ce que ces résultats c'est pas un
rejet de la politique de rigueur
d'austérité des d'austérité mais contre
la caste est ce que la dignité mais on
appelle la casta c'est à dire les tous
les députés tous les
et tous les gens qui sont des
privilégiés parce qu'il a eu beaucoup de
corruption en italie dans toutes les
parties et il n'y a pas été capable dé
changer le système et des données un
signal fort aux pays qui l'ont vraiment
la volonté de changer et alors les gens
ont dit moi je suis tout le monde est en
crise j'ai perdu le travail
mon salaire s'est bloqué et ma fille et
qui cette petite elle a perdu son petit
travail et c'est tout à cause de la
crise dès la sortie européenne de la
crise et que c'est la sortie de
l'austérité et ils ont encore la fête la
casta les privilégiés ils ont encore
fait des dépenses force des choses et là
ça a été un vote contre contre les
députés et contre la haye contre le
parlement en général et contre la sortie
européen
la sortie de la crise européenne
c'est-à-dire vous disiez c'est une gifle
à l'europe
les hommes de l'europe mario monti a
fait 10 % naturellement c'est ça mais
vous ne pouvez pas oublier que au mois
de décembre les gens paient en paient
limo limoux c'est à dire c'est une
taxation sur la propriété qu'est cette
très grande plage et et les gens qu'ils
ont vraiment plus d'argent à cause de la
crise ils ont fait la taxation à deux
mois après le crime il est allé à voter
et donc ils ont voté contre
qui a imposé une taxation qui a vraiment
ni
posé beaucoup de problèmes aux gens
normale est du pays
parce que la récession en italie c'est
très très fort et il va donner je vois
ce moment et c'est la d6 du du
gouvernement donner un signal très fort
qu'il va changer les choses c'est ça
l'italie c'est la troisième économie de
la zone euro
ces deux mille milliards de dettes on
peut pas en rester là qu'est ce qui va
se passer
oui naturellement on peut pas rester là
et je pense que les partis démocratiques
qui a été le premier de toute façon sur
sénat à la chambre des députés mais
conscient il n'y a pas la majorité non
pour pour faire un gouvernement et donc
je crois qu'il voix teintée pas tenter
d'aider faire un gouvernement ceux des
petites réformes des petites choses et
après on sait jamais si on va voter une
autre fois au civ acoquiné avec
justement comment vous voyez l'avenir ce
qui va y avoir une nouvelle et l'extrait
c'est possible c'est beaucoup c'est dans
le bain des tortures napolitaine que
c'est le président de la république
merci giuseppina pas tf1 paternité
alors on l'a dit donc les élections
italienne c'était une gifle à l'europe
il y a aussi cette montée de
l'euroscepticisme en grande bretagne rim
benameur et est allé à la rencontre des
membres de you keep le parti
eurosceptique anglais c'est 20 % des
suffrages aux élections locales
reportage
rob huff et jack sont deux étudiants
londonien ils font partie des ions
guînes dépendance les jeunes do you keep
le parti eurosceptique anglais je
portais toujours une cravate grise au
mont violette ce sont les couleurs de
you keep je ne veux pas qu'on traîne sur
un travailliste
aujourd'hui il rencontre edward membre
du parti conservateur pour débattre de
leurs idées
donc vous concentrer surtout sur la
croissance en grande-bretagne
we you keep étant parti qui veut de
l'europe une europe basée uniquement sur
le commerce
si nous quittons l'union les pays ne
vont pas arrêter d'échanger avec nous
ils ont besoin de ce business et les
deux étudiants ont de bonnes raisons d'y
croire
créée en 93 en plein débat sur le traité
de maastricht
le united kingdom independence party
will you keep est en passe de devenir la
troisième force politique du pays
j'étais intéressé par you keep depuis
2009 quand il n'était qu'un petit parti
eurosceptique
puis j'ai regardé leur autre idée il ya
de bonnes propositions sur l'éducation
la santé les impôts quand une équipe a
dépassé les 10%
j'ai décidé de rejoindre le parti
et à chaque élection les chiffres
montrent direction eastleigh à 1h20 de
londres tous les regards sont braqués
vers cette petite ville une élection
législative partielle si rejouer à
l'amazonie l'occasion to you keep
d'occuper le terrain d'un nous n'avons
pas besoin de l'europe
nous n'en avons pas besoin ça nous coûte
50 millions de livres par jour
ces gens sont assis à bruxelles et des
idées de tous pour nous et en plus et
vivent comme des princes des arguments
anti europe repris par la candidate
locale de ian james
elle a rejoint you keep il ya seulement
deux ans ses chevaux de bataille plus de
réglementations sur l'immigration et la
tenue d'un référendum sortir de l'union
oui on est le seul parti à répondre à la
demande populaire et d'avoir enfin le
choix les seuls
plus maintenant l'idée désormais
reprises par le premier ministre en
personne david cameron
mais pour la candidate de you keep c'est
un argument électoraliste
cameron n'est pas honnête il dit vous
pouvez avoir un référendum en 2010 7 6 6
et 6 et encore 6 4 en chine ce n'est pas
une promesse ni un engagement c'est une
récupération
l'idée du référendum gagne de plus en
plus de terrain dans la classe politique
et le people splash y est pour beaucoup
ce lobby regroupe des pro et des anti
européens
leur objectif commun donner enfin la
parole au peuple anglais qui n'a pas été
consultée depuis 40 ans
open entre les gens pensent que l'union
européenne doit être plus démocratique
de leur côté ceux qui veulent quitter
l'europe pense que le moment est venu
pour eux l'europe est une institution
dépassée qui décline sur le plan
économique
l'angleterre doit se tourner vers le
reste du monde
déjà 130 mille signatures pour leur
pétition en ligne dont une centaine de
députés britanniques parmi eux
jim fitzpatrick contrairement à la
majorité des signataires lui et
pro-européen
j'ai signé la pétition car je veux que
la grande bretagne reste un membre fort
d'une européenne
et si les britanniques peuvent
s'exprimer il voterait majoritairement
pour rester nous n'avons rien à craindre
d'un référendum si nous pouvons régler
la question pour une génération allons-y
n'ayons pas peur
faisons le face à l'europe
les britanniques sont pragmatiques si la
crise économique s'aggrave
l'euroscepticisme risque de gagner du
terrain selon les derniers sondages 60 %
des anglais sont désormais pour une
sortie de l'union européenne
un reportage signé rim benameur alors
nous sommes avec graham watson bonjour
bonjour vous êtes député européen vous
êtes britannique
vous êtes également écossais vous êtes
le président du parti des démocrates et
des libéraux un parti européen on va
dire vous êtes grosso modo centriste ici
en tout cas au parlement à bruxelles
et enfin vous êtes membre de la
commission des affaires étrangères
est-ce que vous à titre personnel vous
êtes pour la tenue d'un référendum en
grande-bretagne
non je suis contre la tenue d'un
référendum dans le sens que ça
endommagent les possibilités d
investissement dans l'économie
britannique sur lesquels nous dépendons
cet immense nombre de postes de travail
donc sa vérité et je suis contre un
référendum sur un sujet où personne ne
sait vraiment pas quels sont les enjeux
mais quand je ne serai pas combien
référendum sur un nouveau traité par
exemple mon parti était en faveur d'un
référendum en grande-bretagne sur une
traité de lisbonne par exemple mais
quand on sait que les britanniques n'ont
pas été consultés sur l'europe depuis
très longtemps
est ce que finalement ce serait pas un
principe de base de la démocratie que de
leur demander ce qu'ils veulent
non la démocratie c'est quoi la
démocratie directe ce sont les
référendums mais souvent les réponses ne
sont pas des réponses à des questions
posées sur les réponses à les personnes
qui posent des questions vous avez un
histoire en france des référendums sur
les traités européens
c'est une histoire malheureuse dirais
même les fonctions dit non nous nous ne
l'avons pas fait
je pense que peut-être la démocratie au
caire
d'ici quelques en une consultation du
public britannique sur le sujet de
l'europe car ce sujet est redevenu très
très très controverse
si vous posez la question aux gens quels
sont les plus chaudes les plus
importants ils n'hésitent pas l'europe
plus important se sèche et l'emploi
c'est la santé c'est l'éducation et les
transports
mais quand même le sujet de l'europe
c'est quelque chose qui est qui qui qui
qui qui nous trouble quand on voit son
un sondage par exemple dit que 60 % des
britanniques veulent maintenant quitté
l'union européenne
or il ya certaines le sondage qui dit 60
il ya certains qui disent 60 en faveur
les sondages s'est pas vraiment
à une bonne mesure juste je pense que si
on faisait une campagne dans un
référendum quitté au reste et la
majorité serait enfin d'autres restaient
penser que la majorité des britanniques
aujourd'hui parce qu'encore une fois
nous l'image qu'on a de l'extérieur de
ce pays c'est que finalement les
britanniques en ont assez david cameron
l'a dit dans son dans son discours il il
ne voit que les côtés négatifs un petit
peu ce que disait ce monsieur c'est à
dire bruxelles ça coûte cher ça fait
d'énormes inutile et c'est donc ce que
vous dites c'est que non en fait c'est
pas ça on peut toujours critiquer
l'europe mais les gens ne savent pas
nous sommes les moins bien en informer
de toutes les europe et un sur ce qu'est
l'europe ce qu'elle fait comment elle
fonctionne mais ce que nous voyons ce
que vous voyez en france on va dosé
entre pc et un nouveau nationalisme
le parti indépendantiste c'est comme le
front national en france c'est un parti
anti immigration
c'est un parti anti coopération
internationale or les grands défis
mondiaux d'aujourd'hui requièrent cette
coopération internationale donc il faut
que la classe politique se justifie pour
ce qu'elle fait dans la construction de
l'europe
alors on a vu dans le reportage tout à
l'heure une candidate aux élections
locales est là une question pour vous et
ensuite on vous retrouve
qu'est ce que c'est le justification
pour rester encore pour continuer d'être
un membre de la communauté européenne
parce que c'est très difficile pour la
population du comprendre pourquoi moment
la question et direct je suis très
heureux d'abord qu'elle parle le
français malheureusement il ya très peu
de mes compatriotes surtout de la
génération succès dante qui parle
français comme ça mais est ce qu'il ya
une justification
absolument comment je ne justifie non
seulement notre économie 3 035 millions
de postes de travail mais aussi notre
sécurité la coopération policière qui
existe entre la grande bretagne et la
france qui nous a permis par exemple de
trouver cet instituteur qui a pris une
fille de 15 ans et qui qui qui qui est
allé en france de la retrouver que nous
on fait avec l'aide de la police
française dans l'europe c'est pas
possible ça sur l'europe c'est pas
possible il faudra toute une série
d'accords bilatéraux
on ne fait plus ça on fait l'europe
ensemble 1,27 bientôt à 28
et ça marche en réalité très très bien
sans nous coûtait trop cher
la dégradation de la note vous avez
perdu jeudi vous mais je pourrais dire
nous aussi puisque les français c'est la
même chose
le ce fameux triple a est ce que en
grande bretagne qu'est ce que c'est on
attribue la cause de cette dégradation à
la mauvaise santé de l'économie de la
zone euro en général on lit cru en
attribue à la mauvaise position de la
zone euro mais on n'a pas raison de le
faire
on doit la tribu et à la mauvaise
position de l'économie de la grande
bretagne parce que malheureusement les
politiques que nous avons introduit pour
essayer de résoudre ce crise économique
n'ont pas très bien fonctionné
alors on a quand même le sentiment je
reviens petit peu sur ces aspects
démocratique et pas uniquement
d'ailleurs sur la sur la grande bretagne
que les européens envoient un certain
nombre de messages répétés alors vous
avez parlé du référent
2005 on a parlé tout à l'heure des
élections en italie peut-être ce
référendum chez vous dans le sentiment à
chaque fois comme ça que les peuples
européens envoient des messages et
qu'ici à bruxelles on les entend par est
ce que vous êtes quand même d'accord et
c'est ce qu'il faudrait il faudrait pas
écouter un petit peu les peuples
d'europe nous les à nous les entendons
nous les écoutons nous avons chacun de
nous nos circonscriptions dans nos pays
respectifs
le problème c'est que nous ne savons
comment répondre sans dire aux gens
franchement si on n'avait pas de l'euro
ce serait la catastrophe totale on ne
peut pas imaginer où c'est difficile
d'imaginer en europe des tribus comme on
l'avait dans le siècle précédent où on
faisait la guerre tous les 30 ans or si
on veut éviter ça il faut construire
l'europe nous construire dans une façon
qui est acceptable pour nos concitoyens
ça c'est plus difficile et le faire
quand nous souffrons tous d'une crise
économique de la demande
c'est encore plus difficile dont nous
allons à mon avis subir une dizaine
d'années de difficultés politiques avec
des nationalismes avec des extrémismes
et il faut que les gens qui croient en
la démocratie
les gens des parties mainstream se
mettent ensemble
si vous dites c'est soit les extrémismes
soit l'europe il n'y a pas de débat de
chemin intermédiaire je ne vois pas en
vue des grands défis de ce monde
une population en croissance rapide et
une migration plus forte que jamais en
vue du défi du changement d'image et de
la sécurité énergétique en vue du défi
de la criminalité organisée de dunes
d'une économie de plus en plus
mondialisé on a fait deux possibilités
sans se mettre ensemble à 500 millions
d'européens ou faire face à tous ces
défis
merci beaucoup on va voir effectivement
si les peuples européens sont persuadés
est convaincu par ce que vous dites
merci graham watson d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
c'est la fin d'europe hebdo on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine et d'ici
là bonne suite de programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires
non